is cloud computing dead in 2023 will AI
replace all the tech jobs out there with
hiring phrases the layoffs happening
everywhere what should you learn this
year to actually land a job in Tech hey
everyone this is Lucy and in this video
I'll be sharing with you the top five
in-demand skills for 2023. I want you to
notice that I didn't say top 5 Tech
careers or top five tech jobs because
the world is constantly changing and
there are so many roles that will be
created in the next three to five years
that don't even exist yet and so if you
approach your career with a growth
mindset and build skills that are in
demand it will not only help you stand
out in the current job market but also
set you up for long-term Career Success
I'm definitely not an expert on the top
five skills I'm about to mention in fact
I'd recommend against trying to master
all of them instead choose one or two of
the skills you find the most interesting
and spend your time learning those for
example two years ago I made the
decision to focus my learning on AWS
cloud and it helped me develop a deeper
understanding of cloud computing which
as a result made me more valuable to
potential employers if you find this
type of content helpful by the way
please give this video a like and let's
dive straight into skill number one
which is artificial intelligence as we
head into 2023 AI is expanding and
transforming at an incredible Pace but
why is that well AI is being used in so
many Industries to solve problems
automate processes and overall just
helps make our lives easier so this is
the release of chat apt there's been one
question on everyone's minds and that is
well artificial intelligence replace the
current jobs in Tech the short answer is
no not yet for now ai is a powerful tool
that can be used to help people get
their work done more effectively for
example if you're a customer service
representative your company might have
an AI power chatbot that can help answer
simple customer questions and it's
because you no longer have to answer the
simple questions you'll have more time
to focus on solving more complex
customer issues now companies are
investing heavily into developing their
AI products as a job Seeker learning AI
can be a game changer for your career
and it's a skill that will continue to
be in demand for years to come in fact
it was predicted that 97 million jobs
involving artificial intelligence will
be created by 2025. if you're excited
about the future of AI but not too sure
where to start I'd recommend checking
out this free video course on Coursera
called AI for everyone it's an 11 hour
course for absolute beginners and helps
you understand AI from the basics the
second in Tech skill to learn in 2023 is
programming again you might ask is AI
going to replace programmers and
software Engineers well experts are
saying that despite the growing impact
of AI programming at the end of the day
is still something that requires human
creativity and decision making many
programming jobs also need people with
soft skills like empathy leadership and
project management in the near future
it's more likely that AI will change the
way that programmers approach their work
and one example of this is using AI to
help programmers with troubleshooting
fixing errors and writing sample code so
for now you can kind of think of it like
a collaboration between Ai and human
programmers if you're interested in
building your programming skills I'd
recommend starting off with the computer
science fundamentals before you dive
into learning a specific programming
language to do this you could enroll in
Harvard University's cs50 introduction
to computer science course which is
self-paced and completely free it gives
you a broad understanding of computer
science and introduces language images
like python SQL and JavaScript but keep
in mind that these days knowing how to
code is often not enough you also need
to continuously learn and adapt and stay
relevant in the tech industry this could
involve sharpening your soft skills or
trying out new ways to improve your
productivity okay before we move on to
skill number three I'd like to take a
moment to tell you about today's video
sponsor akaflow akaflow is a Time
blocking platform that has completely
changed the way I manage my tasks and
schedule as a full-time content creator
I was struggling to keep track of
everything I needed to do and was
constantly juggling between multiple
apps to stay organized but what akiflow
does is it pretty much consolidates
everything all in one place for example
I can now have my to-do list and Google
Calendar side by side and from the
acaflow app I can simply drag and drop
tasks into my calendar I'm also a big
user of notion and you can see here that
you can do the same thing with any task
you have from your notion pages acaflow
also integrates with slack Asana Trello
and many other tools you can even set up
a keyboard shortcut to easily add tasks
without leaving your current window so
overall I'd recommend checking out Echo
flow if you're someone looking to
improve your time management and
productivity to start using acaflow you
can head to the link in the description
below for a free trial now let's get
back to the video the third skill which
is obviously my personal favorite is
cloud computing if you've been watching
this channel for a while you'll know
that most of my videos are focused on
helping people land a job in the cloud
industry it's where I started my career
almost three years ago and I still think
it's one of the best areas in Tech to
work in I won't talk too much about this
skill because I have like 20 other
videos explaining this but cloud
computing has been around for over a
decade now and it's still growing
rapidly if you'd like to build your
Cloud skills I'd recommend working
towards getting a beginner level
certification from either AWS Azure or
gcp and then from there working on cloud
projects to Showcase what you've learned
I'll include a link to a video I
published recently on five free courses
to learn AWS alright skill number four
is centered around cyber security and to
put a simply cyber security is all about
helping protect computers servers and
systems from malicious attacks and so as
the tech industry continues to grow
cyber threats will continue to increase
which then creates a bigger demand for
people with cyber security skills when I
was working at AWS we used to say that
security is job zero which meant that
it's even more important than any number
one priority because when you think
about it no matter how great a company's
products are if they're not very secure
it can cause serious consequences for
both the company and their customers to
start learning about cyber security one
free course to look into is cybery's
Introduction to it and cyber security
course I haven't tried it out myself but
I've seen a few other YouTubers say
great things about it so yeah if you end
up doing the course let me know what you
think another resource is this two hour
long AWS security fundamentals course
this course is more focused on security
within the context of cloud computing so
for those of you who are learning AWS
Cloud this might be an interesting
course for you last but not least we
have data science which is pretty
similar to cyber security in that it's
at the core of almost every business
with the increasing amount of data being
generated every day companies need
people who can analyze visualize and
make sense of all of it data science has
always been a field that requires a
strong knowledge of maths statistics and
coding so before diving straight into
learning data science I suggest taking
the time to develop these fundamental
skills but as always make sure you do
your own research to decide what you
want to focus your learning on this year
and there you have it five in-demand
tech skills I recommend for 2023. if
you've watched this video all the way to
the end please give it a like and
comment below with what skills you'd
like to build this year alright bye for
now
[Music]